I'm on a big burrito you get it too
spicy though oh it's from Becky go ahead
here's the message Brian just proposed
we're engaged haha oh my god oh that is
so sweet isn't it except why is
everybody getting married seriously I
can't even look at my social media
anymore oh yeah Miss Jane wedding
pictures and wedding pictures and guess
what else more wedding pictures but it
is so nice to see your friends at their
weddings I mean they are so happy oh wow
ah that really silenced you what do you
think about getting married to you yes
obviously me I would hope no I mean well
I feel like our life is awesome right
now it's just me and you we travel them
we go out to eat and we do all the
things we want to do Yeah right yeah
so how was getting married gonna make
that any better right hmm okay it just
feels like as soon as people get marry
they immediately become boring quiet
down I would've come the season finale
I'm gonna move now let's get to the
backsplash look at that hold on that is
ridiculous that it's never gonna happen
talk about saying that it what happened
however you can't deny it's a
possibility you're the one who likes
backsplashes so much because they're
beautiful okay moving on and we just
hung out with Andrew and Monica last
week come on they're an awesome married
couple yeah one time the good world is
about to get crazy
we wearing turtleneck sweater I don't
know when did it become a thing again
I'll tell you what it is it's a married
thing yeah okay seriously all jokes
aside are you really not interested in
getting married because you always talk
about wanting a family so I just assumed
that this I do want a family but you
don't have to be married to have kids if
you don't get married you can't get
divorced
so it didn't work for your parents but
you know what they had you and we are
together whatever comes our way we are
gonna figure it out I mean wanna be
great girls together who's ready to go
back to the 90s you're a total Betty I'm
not going to be losing my tee time you
don't know that you look like you're
probably gonna be like bald in the mouth
oh it's a thing well mouth ball does
watch out
so if mm-hmm if yeah we get married
you'd be cool with me maybe changing
careers opening up that restaurant Jeff
absolutely I am gonna support you
whether we're married or not I love you
let me - oh it's fine Becky
here's the message do you use there's
already 200 people on the invite list I
don't know how we are going to pay for
this and that's exactly what I'm talking
about
what if we just like have a really small
destination wedding I could get on board
with that